sometimes you can show your side of
something doesn't mean you change
someone's opinion but with humor
so if you show someone a documentary
that's clearly biased people are gonna
oh well this filmmaker just you know
this is the lobbyist paid him to do you
know these different things but
humor is a very effective way of getting
people to kind of let down their guard
and maybe for one moment entertain
something whether it's their own fault
in something or just seeing something in
a different light
yeah so that's one thing you know here's
it's funny this is a blueprint for
storytelling
and it's not quite humor but it what's
great about
really great storytelling if you think
of and i've used this as a model in some
of my movies
to kill a mockingbird to me in so many
ways is like
brilliant storytelling and and and i'll
explain pretty simply why
in this fight is the only book she wrote
right then the movie's great
um the movie's about racism
and there's um i remember well there's a
um
a young black fellow who's being tried
for something he didn't do
and as a viewer of the audience you're
thinking how could these people be so
biased and racist and and and you're you
just
can't fathom it right the subplot in the
story is
the kids have a neighbor boo radley
and they're sort of totally afraid he's
the boogeyman
and as the story unfolds and the
audience is super afraid of him and
you're like horrified of this boo radley
guy
and you're thinking man this is kind of
crazy but that guy's you know
evil for sure by the end of the movie
he ends up being the sweetest man
possible and i thought
well that's brilliant filmmaking because
you look at them and go how could they
be racist towards this
young black kid meanwhile ask the
audience you were racist
towards this guy boo radley because you
didn't know enough about him
and it was the ignorance and and to me
that's like perfect storytelling
we were actually sucked into being
racist and now we can suddenly relate to
why other people can be racist
and it has to do with ignorance and it's
just those layers is like what makes
storytelling amazing and
you know you can do it even more in in
movies with with those kind of layers
but
you know it all starts with the writing
and then it comes to the next level
which is the
which is the movie um for me that's the
way i look at it obviously books
stand on their own um yeah so um i don't
know how i got that tangent but that
that sort of a model so i made the movie
around the world in 80 days
and i used that sort of template i
wanted the movie be about
travel and how it opens you up because
i've traveled my whole life
and and i think a lot of americans
didn't travel enough and the more you
travel the more you get more
you know tolerant and understanding of
other cultures and you're suddenly not
fearful and it just makes you a better
person it makes you feel
more well-rounded and in the story
phillius fogg
is an inventor and he's up against the
uh royal academy of science and they
believe that everything that could be
invented
has already been invented and he thinks
how could these guys be so pig-headed
and and not believe this and he gets in
this adventure to go around the world
meanwhile he in his own right is really
big-headed
and close-minded and isn't open to art
and all these other things
but he goes on this journey around the
world he meets jackie chan plays
passport two he meets a french artist
he he doesn't even know what art is and
he thinks it's crazy and stupid in a
waste of time
by the end of the movie he becomes a
full-rounded person
he gets to fully realize his dream that
a man can fly
and he they wins to bet on a flying
machine i embellished the original book
and movie
and to me it was the same i used um
uh um to kill a mockingbird in that
make him see them as one way and then
realize he himself was as
as closed-minded as they were so that
kind of like double layer thing is a
great
device that you can use in storytelling
and
so yeah i i like that kind of stuff when
this layer is
going on like that
you